Hey guys, Backyard Scientist here. I've come up with a fun new game.
I like to call it, "Don't try this at home".
It's simple. Just set up a string of lighters in a circle so each flame is below the next one.
The flames will eventually melt through the plastic, causing a small explosion.
In order to win the game you just need to choose the first color to explode.
You can play too. Go down to the comments section and tell me what color you think's going to explode first.
What do you choose?
: Blue
: I choose yellow.
: You can't choose yellow! There's two yellows.
Whoo! <exclamation>
Oh no! <laughter> Whoo!
<laughter>
<hiss>
Whuh
No, wha, that was yellow <hiss> but it didn't explode.
That was...
<explosion>
WHAAAOOO!
Wha hooo!
: That one exploded.
Technically yellow was the first one to explode, but the fireball came from green.
: This is definitely not an indoor game.
: I agree.
: <clap> Let's play again.
: Alriiight
So I asked a bunch of people on my Facebook page what they thought would happen...
...and if you got the right answer, congratulations.
Some people thought the order that I lit them would matter and it turns out it did matter.
The first lighter I lit was actually the last one to explode 'cause it was the last one to have flame touching it.
I'm going to eliminate that variable because I've built a device that triggers all the flames automatically with electricity.
Right, I wanted to make a simple, easy, stupid video then you gotta go and throw this science... in it....
: Science in it. Thanks a lot guys. Now I have to work.
Let's get started.
<loud buzz>
<small buzz>
Alright
<clap>
<hiss>
<hiss> <woof>
Whoo hooo!
<woof>
<blowing>
: Well that one had a few fireballs.
: Yeah.
: That one had more.
: That one got... that was more intense.
Uh, uh, there it goes.
<hiss>
Oooo
Nope!
<hiss> <hiss> <whoosh> <whoosh> <whoosh>
Whaaaaa!
Let's see if they've got any juice left in 'em.
<buzz>
: Yeah
There's gonna have drippy melted glass like...
<click> <laugh>
<blow> <laughter>
<cough>
Alright, if your parents haven't blocked my channel yet, don't let them see the next part of the video.
I've made an expansion pack for the game that's got five big lighters instead of the smaller ones.
It's fun for the whole family and it's a great time to cash in on your homeowner's insurance.
But on second thought, maybe I should take this outside.
<click>
<background> Well I guess not all the...
<hisss>
The explosions weren't as big as I thought, and I guess that's because these big lighters only hold a small amount of fuel concealed in a big package.
Oh well, I've got one more trick up my sleeve.
Alright, let me show you one more cool trick.
So now you have all these lighters left over and nothing to do with them. But...
There's a cool little trick you can do.
If you take off this metal case...
...and then remove this wheel...
...there should be a little flint inside like this and a spring.
So take out the flint. Take out the spring.
And then untwist the spring a little bit so it looks like that.
Take the flint... and... wrap it up like that.
Alright so heat up the flint till it's red hot with the lighter and I'm gonna throw it on the ground. Check it out.
<hiss> <crackle>
Alright guys, that's it for this video.
If you want to keep watching, go check out that styrofoam rocket plane video
It's super fun - most fun I've had making a video, probably.
You can also follow me on Facebook, Instagram, and Twitter so you can be a part of any other polls I have...
...and it's a great way to reach me if you have a comment.
Please, I get so many on my YouTube channel it's hard to see everybody.
Alright, see ya. Bye.